[Music]
every once in a while esports sees the
rise
of a true competitor a world-class
one in a million superstar who quite
simply
has it all these individuals have the
plays
nothing a nice break from him but it's
going to be all down to stewie
oh my god what the [ __ ] they have the
personality
oh god i love it yes yeah that is mad
are you right now
and finally their unmistakable it factor
because at the end of the day esports
isn't just about dominating the
competition
it's about doing it in style the hell am
i looking at
that is a bunch of uh cat ears or i
don't know what's going on
but what if i told you that one of the
sweetest silliest and most
skilled superstars in league of legends
is one you've probably never heard of
meet lee cacao buen kwan a giggly
glasses-wearing jungler who despite once
being recognized as one of the greatest
competitors his game has ever seen
has somehow spent the latter half of his
career spiraling into irrelevance
thanks in part to his ill-fated
arrogance
and some truly terrible luck the two
secret weapons cacao has managed to
cement himself
as the korean divinity that not only
never was
but really should have been you know it
seems like cacao is one of those players
that you know
hit a high high very quickly um and was
at that peak but
then you know for whatever reason
couldn't slash didn't want to sustain
that
the crazy thing about cacao is that he
isn't washed
he's still arguably as good as he ever
was so what exactly is stopping him from
becoming the household name he was meant
to be
[Music]
okay so if you're not familiar with
cacao then chances are you haven't been
watching league for very long you're
also definitely not one of those
hipsters who thinks that league pretty
much
peaked in 2014 and has been going
downhill ever since
renowned for his happy-go-lucky attitude
aggressive jungle play
and being an all-around cutie pie cacao
has long been recognized as one of
korea's most explosive
talents can't do the 1v4 just yet
ah quite rockless on rookie very nice
and goon gets that kill
really well played there arrow just sits
there takes on zephyr now he's on the
gorilla
another kill kha'zix gets that one in
the resets again
cacao comes over for the triple
and that is gonna be an ace his
potential star power was so obvious to
kt rolster that he was recruited by the
org at the tender age of 17.
now from the get-go it was clear that
cacao was something special
the kind of competitor that orgs should
be salivating over
hr doesn't see this anyway as i was
saying
cacao ticked a lot of boxes for kt
he wasn't just marketable because he had
endless charisma
he also happened to be one of the
fiercest junglers in the world
and cacao going back underneath that
turret of johnny in big trouble though a
lowly support under turret against four
people
unfortunately that's not going to work
too well he lives for now though
are you kidding me well
but now he's a bit caught watch the wild
growth onto him
and there's cacao coming in they get the
alt save a bit low
the combination of his skill on the rift
and his magnetic personality
drew fans to him and it wasn't long
before they dubbed his iconic
infectious laugh the cackle
[Laughter]
for two years cacao inspired fear
admiration and rivalry whilst helping to
spearhead kt's rosters to success
the peak of his career came in the
summer of 2014 when following his
infamous grand finals lost to skt the
year prior cacao rallied his way back to
the most
coveted and competitive stage in league
and emerged not only victorious
but as one of the best players in the
going world take you right here the
nexus is going down
all they need to do is focus it oh my
gosh they're doing it
kt arrows champions
it may sound like people being crushed
in the trash can back from the death
star but that is actually the sound of
joy
listen to them they're dying auntie
it's a beautiful sight well deserved
lost his first
champions final he's back he is the king
and what a fitting player for envy
as the reigning champions of league's
most competitive regional circuit
kt looked like serious contenders to win
worlds that year but they didn't even
come close
why well because as it turns out in
order to win
worlds you have to make it to worlds
you see before 2015 winning the summer
split didn't automatically book your
spot at worlds like it does now
and several days after their epic
domestic title win
katie had to face off against najin
white shield in a qualifier to
compete on league's biggest stage the
problem was that cacao and kt
assumed that as defending champions
they'd just breeze through their
opponents
and that cocky nonchalant attitude
proved to be costly it's gonna be really
hard
for shield to save this one oh my
grandparents he comes in
oh goo god and he got baron whoa
able to take with the orianna damage and
there's a kill for zeph on to johnny on
top of that
but really sloppy play from cacao to
even let that happen
in the qualifiers for worlds but this is
the right time to catch on fire
i would say so cacao getting a little
bit caught here goo coming in there's
the death mark on the cacao will be able
to get out no problem window a little
bit late to the party
rasana jumps away but there's one kill
already solar player slows people down
but there's no follow-up
wow interesting kt is ahead of two on
turrets and it looks like nacho wants to
get some picks arrow a little bit low
oh looks good he has to back off though
nacho needs to be careful here
a kill for watch but it's not over yet
someday knocks zepho away
what a brawl double kill though for
watch coming and save just hacking away
from the back lines and another big
fight an ace
and a triple kill and i guess you can
give up top turret for that yeah that's
okay
again with these little bitty skirmishes
that are happening
and there's cacao that is oh
not a happy cacao face yeah believe it
or not guys the champion summer
champions kt
arrows eliminated 3-0 in the gauntlet
and najin shield
goes on to fight for a spot at worlds
that's right
not only did cacao and kt get [ __ ]
clapped
they became the first roster who won
champion summer
to not qualify for worlds and that
is where all of cacao's problems began
now it's no secret that up until
recently korea was head and shoulders
above the rest in terms of international
dominance
it was also very obvious that it was
getting on the nerves of the other
regions
but it would feel a lot better if we
just crushed these smug asians
cacao was pretty much the epitome of
what doublelift was talking about
guileless as he was cacao was a god
and
now it was also around this time that
china began investing
unholy amounts of moolah into their own
league of legends scene
specifically by poaching the best that
korea had to offer
[Music]
thanks to the absurdly fat paycheck
invictus gaming was offering him
and what he felt would be a free ticket
to worlds cacao became one of the first
of his region's superstars to
participate in what would later be
called
the great korean
now even though the lpl proved to be
more than just a cakewalk for cacao and
ig
the team still qualified for worlds
cacao finally had the opportunity to
step onto the stage he'd seemed
destined to dominate that is until an
unexpected disaster
struck i think ig is going to win
because
uh i'm a good friend of ig's coach and
he told me that they have secret weapon
[Music]
insider info he told me that kakao
maybe we're choosing hacrum or lee sin
jungling
and he said that if it really if he
really picks that
we have to put strong attention to him
and
he said they are going to pick kalista
and cannonbot
and well so now everybody listening is
just going to ban those out
but what if that's the what if that's
the plan what if they ban those out
there
you're throwing everybody no i'm scared
there's also other one
other two secret weapon is
took to the analyst desk and leaked ig's
secret strats
live on camera
in the middle of groups obviously it's
one of the basic
you know requirements of being on camera
talent or
or you know being a caster of any kind
in any sports space is that you don't
share information between teams you know
it's certainly you know
just not at all there's no excuse
whether it's public or not naturally
ig's tournament hopes were sent
into the [ __ ] and seemingly cacao's
career
along with them
[Music]
despite the crushing disappointment of
bombing out of worlds cacao was
determined to stick it out in china
but his dissent only continued he joined
one you dream in the chinese lspl in the
spring of 2016
but even with the talented korean the
team was relegated after having a poor
performance throughout the split
come 2017 cacao made his way to the west
and joined misfits gaming's
up-and-coming eu lcs roster in the
spring
where he proved that he was still
capable of flashes of brilliance
i thought that they could go for the
aggressive play but with the presence of
cacao he's forced to ruin our memento
looks like that from the void spike
flash forward taste the fear is not
enough
red buff slows down memento cacao needs
to get in range the cool downs
not gonna connect the overload is locked
out cacao turns around tonight
knights running a little low on mana 200
hp
sidesteps gets the kill in the previous
game
he's slacking so badly this game
only a hundred and forty four obviously
okay oh yeah chunky steals it
here comes the tp a joke the shield on
sven cacao he's got any
kicked him he's got him sven's going to
go down now he's just alive
look at the life steal finally taken out
shockwave
that's going to be enough no near the
grass by the power of evil needs a few
more seconds before he can
oh [ __ ] shockwave found nobody cacao
looks for samax here goes legendary it's
21 kills
four misfits are looking for more xerxes
collateral damage to safety cacao sonic
wave the least symptom is strong today
exiles rooted in place shut down by
power of evil cacao's not done yet
he's looking for xerxes ga gets popped
ignot throws down a ward for vision
where's the rest of unicorns they're
running for their lives
stunningly enough cacao was kicked from
misfits due to the language barrier
between him and his teammates
in spite of the fact that he'd put on
what they called
a handful of mvp level performances
after a short layover in turkey cacao
finally returned home to korea
as something of a prodigal son a former
superstar who
since abandoning his region for a
paycheck would have to re-earn
his fan's approval and absurdly enough
he did just not in the way everyone
expected
after being relegated from the lck on
jin air cacao
was kicked determined to make it back to
the top
he joined apk prince whom he helped get
into challengers and
qualify for the actual lck
[Music]
and shockingly after getting his second
lease on life
cacao left the team why
whatever the reason for his departure
cacao's career was in a tough spot
any other player might have given up but
he wasn't finished
he bounced back in 2020 by joining
sayorabiole gaming
in challengers and went on to win the
spring split with them even though they
were being heralded by the community as
the team to enable cacao's
long-awaited return things sadly didn't
pan out that way in their fight for lck
promotion
the azir does have to fall for it but
that is all the damage available for
sirable now
taken off the board gorilla there
doesn't even eat his grey health doesn't
need to
as this next is going to be taken down
and congratulations to sandbox
and welcome back to the lck as of right
now
it isn't clear what the future holds for
this cosmically unlucky jungler
he's gone back to turkey to play for
supermassive
but who knows for how long the hope of
course is that he'll return to korea
and pick up where he left off in 2014
and
sure to some that might sound crazy but
here's the thing
through all of his unfortunate mishaps
and the fact that his celebrity is a
shadow of what it once
was cacao has never stopped trying to
reclaim his place at the top
and unlike some of his now retired peers
he still might be good enough to pull it
off
the true tragedy of cacao is that he's
been forced to watch as his former
teammates went on to reach
unprecedented heights while he spent
years
desperately fighting for the career he
should have had
but to his credit in addition to being
the unluckiest superstar in league
history
he might also be the most dogged it's
simply not in his nature to give up
here comes cacao he's available lands a
sonic wave and resonating strike the
damage back and forth
taste of fear defensively but the crowds
helping out a cacao gets first blood
at 24 years of age cacao still has time
to pen
triumph into the final chapters of his
career and while it remains to be seen
whether he can
reclaim his former glory one thing is
for certain he'll always be a figure
that the community will
celebrate for his obvious and undying
love of the game
you know i remember his demeanor and his
personality more than his gameplay at
this point you know like he was a great
jungler but
um you know he was also just an
extremely entertaining personality right
he was always laughing easily and
loudly you know just seemed to more than
a lot of other players just seem to be
having just a ton of fun being a pro
gamer
and that passion for the game in spite
of the
years he spent being beaten down by it
is what
makes cacao such a compelling character
perhaps more than any other league of
legends
has been of his caliber he's the one
everyone has
always hoped would make a comeback and
for the sake of that lovely
lilting and beautifully obnoxious laugh
let's hope that he does anything can
happen in champions
faker was so good at league he might
even be silver and dota
all honestly though i'm riot games trash
now like i've been playing so much
valorent lately that like i
anyway as i was saying saying
that's right not only did cacao and kt
lose but they got
[ __ ] clapped becoming the first